I want you to have a look at the
right-hand side of the public because
before we look at this this is what I
mean by a harder identity okay so here
of course it's hard up it's it's messy
we're doing this thing okay how do
identities there are three main
techniques methods that we can use to
prove these kinds of things on top of
knowing what NCR is on top of knowing
like factorials are you need to be able
to do some other more clever things okay
now one more caveat before you actually
do the questions 90% of the time maybe
even more than members in the time
they'll give you a bit of a lead Ian
right there'll be like a partay
it's like sure this right or they'll say
consider blah blah blah they'll tell you
what to think about and then you can go
ahead and you can actually solve the
question but in a very small number of
cases you'll get no lead
they'll just tell you and this is one of
you garbled here's a result off you go
from scratch I want you to prove this
okay so in all those cases basically
what you want to start with is the
binomial theorem and then you want to do
something to it which I'm gonna
illustrate over here have a look at this
result you don't need to write this down
because we've done this was up before it
takes two lines to get from here to here
right I just think about verb binomial
theorem okay so for example here's one
way that I could write the new year what
are we going to get on the left-hand
side what some of things am I going to
get
but let's start from zero go all the way
up to end because there should be n plus
1 times yeah what's going to be attorney
general term that is NCR like this a
couple different ways I think I was
probably the most sensible way to do it
I could do with the are on the ones and
then the invite us are here but that's
this is what I was trying to avoid
yesterday right so this looks like the
nice cleanest way to write it
okay now to get from here to here like
this is what I just wrote down totally
quotable right like that's the binomial
theorem in a very simple form and now I
wanted to do is pick a value that gets
me from here to here do you see that
pick a value that gets me from here in
here clearly it's x equals one so if I
substitute in x equals one
watch what happens on the left hand side
you get the sum of these coefficients
times a whole bunch of ones which I
don't care about and then over here
you've got one plus one that's it you
don't have to do anything else
okay so there were two parts of that you
started with the binomial theorem and
then you peaked a value with the peak
develop have a look over here okay this
is up because this is harder identities
is you go a little more general so 1 and
X are particular things that you put
into the binomial they could be anything
right any to turn to your like okay
raised to some kind of power so this is
an even more general way of stating the
binomial theorem again it's the sum of a
whole bunch of things what am I going to
be adding up in this case oh sorry yeah
oh very good and then I've got some of
these and some of these right and
depending on which term I got they'll
have more or less or the same above okay
so I guess I could write it like this of
special be outside and be ^ great
because we know these always out
okay so what you know if I could just
state this just like you did over here
you stare at this and you think what am
i put in here to get me to here now in
this case it was easy because there's
only one thing you need to think about
have a look at this guy
so I've said it in this way do you
notice what my binomial coefficients are
where the binomial convince' they're all
here but this is the thing posting
posting plus thing tossing so this
actually corresponds to even though
written on the right this corresponds to
the left-hand side do you agree with
that okay this therefore Koster's to the
left-hand side of it here yeah so I need
to pick some values an A and baby
somehow there's a bandaid that won't
give me is he okay
on the left-hand side do you see that
okay now there's lots of different ones
I can choose but it's in my interest to
just come up with the quickest easiest
one okay now it's just an introduction
so this time I'm going to tell you the
values that I picked do I'm going to
substitute
yep it will be easier if I do right
you'll see why I'm a second man okay
because in broad terms arithmetic is
easier than a draw so if I can deal with
numbers I'd prefer to do that because
numbers like simplify out ones they
disappear but negative B's never
disappear they have to stay in there
until they can tell me something okay
so I'm gonna just try this try these
guys out with this okay so the left-hand
sides the EasyBib right it's gonna be
negative 1 plus 1 to the power R and
that's gonna become 0 in a second just
good what happens on the right hand side
some wrong not to end they still there
YZ and B so I haven't done any
substitution just yet okay now I'm ready
here we go negative 1 what how you think
so far make sense ok by the way this is
I should have given her a name this is
never one solution so you just start
from the binomial theorem be back over
here and we want to substitute some
values that will get us to the value the
result that we're trying to prove ok
have a look do you see we're pretty much
there in fact the hard work was thinking
about which values to choose and you
will gain a bit of an eye for these
negative 1 1 & 0
they're the most common values because
they make things disappear they simplify
turns out a lot let's have a look on the
left hand side I've got 0 on the right
hand side I've got this guy disappearing
right he's a factor of a multiple of 1 I
should say so therefore he contributes
nothing to all of these guys right I can
write this out as an actual series now
because this is simple enough to work
with what's the first term in the series
gonna be okay so I'm actually gonna
write it out I go and see 0 because
there's the first value bar times
negative 1 to the power of 0 which of
course is by itself one tick
okay have a look at the next time the
next value is 4 R equals 1
so I'm gonna go NC 1 times how many lots
of negative one one of them okay I need
one more to complete a pattern to
establish a pattern and then I'm gonna
get to the end you can see now I'm just
stating this thing right except I'm
pointing this minus one to the end out
the front where it belongs this is just
a number and you can see this is this as
a result I want to be I guess
zero I could by the left hand side right
hand side around the way that I want but
I think you're probably happy to see
that there could look and you're done
okay so something that looks
intimidating and very messy it's kind of
the whole point behind binomial theorem
that it's like yeah it looks awful but
the binomial theorem itself helps you
just package these down to something
that's very very manageable the hardest
part is to know what values to pick and
that comes a bit with practice okay yes
sorry I'm ending on the n1 so what do
you think of the first method
substitution okay if you don't get give
it any leading at all just start with
the binomial theorem write it down and
then look at what you've got next to
what they've got and see how you can
make a comparison okay so it says